a lower GI endoscopy also called
colonoscopy or sigmoidoscopy allows your
doctor to view the mucosal lining of
your lower gastrointestinal tract
the procedure is used as a screening
test in individuals with no symptoms or
to help diagnose unexplained abdominal
pain rectal bleeding or a change in
bowel habits it is capable of detecting
inflammation infections ulcers
diverticulosis intestinal narrowing
colorectal polyps cancer or other
problems that may be present the
procedure is performed using an
endoscope which is along then flexible
tube with a light and a tiny video
camera attached to the end the camera
transmits an image to a monitor in a
sigmoidoscopy the endoscope only reaches
to the top of the descending colon in a
colonoscopy the endoscope reaches
through the entire length of the colon
to where it connects to the small
intestine
before a colonoscopy an intravenous line
will be started and you will be offered
pain medication and a sedative your
blood pressure pulse and the oxygen
level in your blood will be monitored
and you may also receive oxygen through
a nasal cannula during the procedure a
sigmoidoscopy does not usually require
this kind of preparation or monitoring
the presence of the endoscope and the
air may cause you to feel cramping or
pressure and the need to pass gas this
is considered a normal part of the
procedure your doctor may ask you to
change your position slightly to help
maneuver the endoscope more easily
through the curves of your lower
intestine if you experience pain tell
your doctor immediately in some cases
your doctor may find it necessary to
take a biopsy a biopsy helps distinguish
between benign and cancerous tissues and
can help determine the cause of bleeding
inflammation or diarrhea biopsies are
often taken even when your doctor does
not suspect cancer if one or more polyps
are discovered your doctor will
generally remove them in a procedure
called a Polly Peck t'me he or she will
usually use a snare to remove the polyps
and then cauterize their bases to
control bleeding after the procedure you
will be monitored for about half an hour
until the effects of any medications you
have taken wear off you will need to
arrange for a ride home particularly
after a full colonoscopy